in the past few minutes President Trump
sent Russia a strong warning as he plans
a possible missile attack on Syria the
president tweeted Russia vows to shoot
down any and all missiles fired at Syria
get ready Russia because they will be
coming nice and new and smart you
shouldn't be partners with a gas killing
animal who kills his people and enjoys
it Seth Doane is near the Syrian border
in Lebanon where tensions are rising
south good morning good morning
president Trump has been talking with
his counterparts in France in the United
Kingdom about coordinating a strong
response to the alleged chemical attack
in Syria as the world tries to send a
message that the use of chemical weapons
will not be tolerated
following that suspected chemical attack
which activists say killed at least 40
people and left victims struggling to
breathe Syria has invited the
independent organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons to
investigate it's not clear whether a
visit from chemical weapons experts may
delay any military strike on Syria Syria
and its ally Russia have denied the
chemical attack took place Russia sent
its own military investigators to the
scene who claimed to have found no
traces of chemical weapons Russia has
also accused the white helmets of
spreading propaganda by releasing video
purportedly showing remnants of chemical
munitions Russia has not only been
serious strongest ally on the
battlefield flying fighter jets to carry
out airstrikes but diplomatically - UN
Security Council deliberations Tuesday
Russia vetoed a u.s. resolution that
pushed for an independent investigation
into the chemical attack history will
record that on this day Russia chose
protecting a monster over the lives of
the Syrian people
Russia's UN Ambassador countered that
the u.s. was trying to mislead the
international community and was making a
step toward confrontation the USS Donald
cook a guided missile destroyer is among
the u.s. military assets in the region
it's capable of launching Tomahawk
cruise missiles the same that were used
following the sarin chemical attack last
year Syrian forces are on high alert and
a Russian diplomat here in Lebanon has
said any US missiles would be shot down
and even u.s. launch sites could be
targeted Gail all right Seth Doane thank
you every time I see that video it just
it makes you sick when you see what's
happening there yeah I'm sort of stunned
by what the president said this morning
I mean saying that the missiles will be
coming nice and new and smart I mean
talk about projecting what you're going
to do yeah it's a promise
yeah I promise I mean it's a new kind of
redline if you will yeah you know we've
never had and also it's fascinating to
hear them talk about the monster that
Russia is supporting Russia has been
supporting that person that the
administration is calling a monster for
a very long time in US policy has been
to let that continue that seems like a
bit of a heads up though